TRUMP SURELY, BUT ALSO THE OTHER
SECTORS OF GOVERNMENT AS WELL,
INCLUDING THE FBI.
AND THAT'S THE "ANGLE" ."
IN THE LAST HOUR YOU HEARD JOHN
SOLOMON TELL US ABOUT SPECIAL
COUNSEL BOB MUELLER'S POSSIBLE
CONFLICT OF INTEREST DUE TO HIS
TIES TO A RUSSIAN OLIGARCH.
JOHN IS NOW HERE WITH AN EVEN
NEWER BREAKING SERIES OF
DEVELOPMENTS THAT WERE JUST
POSTED MOMENTS AGO ON THE HILL.
NOBODY HAS HEARD THIS BEFORE, IT
IS STUNNING STUFF.
JOHN, WHAT ELSE SHOULD WE KNOW?
I READ THROUGH YOUR PIECE ABOUT
A HALF HOUR AGO WHEN IT WAS
POSTED.
NOW WE FIND OUT THAT IN
SEPTEMBER OF 2016, THIS GUY MADE
OUT TO BE THIS BIG BOGEYMAN BY
THE POLITICAL PARTIES, ON A
SANCTIONS LIST.
HE IS VISITED BY THREE FBI
AGENTS WHO WANT HIM TO DO WHAT?
>> IT'S GREAT.
HE'S ALREADY BEEN VERY HELPFUL
TO THE FBI, $25 MILLION OF HIS
OWN MONEY TRYING TO HELP THEM
RESCUE ONE OF THEIR OWN AGENTS
IN IRAN.
THEY HAVE HIS TRUST.
THEY GIVE HIM EIGHT OR TEN
PASSPORTS TO COME IN AND THEN
TWO MONTHS BEFORE THE ELECTION
HE'S ASLEEP IN HIS APARTMENT IN
NEW YORK AND HE GETS A KNOCK ON
THE DOOR BY SOME OF THE SAME FBI
AGENTS THAT WORKED WITH HIM ON
THE EARLY OPERATION AND THEY
SAID WE THINK TRUMP'S CAMPAIGN
AND RUSSIA ARE COLLUDING ON THE
ELECTION AND HE LET OUT A BIG
LAUGH.
>> Laura: WEIGHT.
THE AGENTS SAY TO A RUSSIAN
BILLIONAIRE.
>> CLOSE TO PUTIN.
>> Laura: SUPPOSEDLY CLOSE TO
PUTIN.
ALL THE MILLIONAIRES KNOWN.
THERE WAS A THAT'S NOT A BIG
DEAL.
THEY SAY TO HIM WE HAVE AN IDEA
OR A THEORY THAT HE IS COLLUDING
THROUGH, WHAT, PAUL MANAFORT?
>> PAUL MANAFORT WAS THE FIRST
DIMENSION.
HERE'S THE FUNNY PART.
HE HAD A TORTURED RELATIONSHIP
WITH PAUL MANAFORT.
HE HIRED HIM AS A POLITICAL
CONSULTANT, WASN'T HAPPY.
GAVE HIM SOME MONEY FOR A
INVESTMENT.
THEY HAD A FALLING OUT.
SAID HE STOLE MY MONEY AND TOOK
IT INTO THE UNITED STATES.
THE GUY THEY GO TO IS AN ENEMY
OF PAUL MANAFORT.
AND SAID COULD YOU HELP US -- HE
LAUGHS.
HE BREAKS OUT IN LAUGHTER SAYING
IT'S PREPOSTEROUS.
HE  IS TO TAKE THIS SERIOUSLY AD
THEY      HE
SAID I DON'T LIKE THE GUY.
THERE'S NO CHANCE THEY'RE USING
PAUL MANAFORT TO COORDINATE AN
ELECTION AND THAT'S IMPORTANT
FOR TWO REASONS.
IT'S TWO MONTHS BEFORE THE
ELECTION.
IT'S BEFORE THE FISA APPLICATION
AND HERE IS SOMETHING THAT THE
FBI TRUSTED PREVIOUSLY TO GIVE
THEM RELIABLE INFORMATION.
SPENT HIS OWN MONEY DOING FBI
WORK AND NOW THEY'RE TELLING HIM
NO COLLUSION.
DOES THE FISA COURT KNOW THIS?
I BET NOT.
>> Laura: SO OUR VIEWERS
UNDERSTAND THIS.
WE HAVE A SITUATION WITH THREE
FBI AGENTS GO TO THIS RUSSIAN
BILLIONAIRE'S APARTMENT, WHO
ONLY CAN COME TO THE
UNITED STATES BECAUSE HE IS
SUPPOSEDLY A BAD GUY, WHICH BY
ALL INDICATIONS HE WAS TRYING TO
HELP BOB WETHINGTON GET OUT OF
IRAN, A 30-YEAR VETERAN OF THE
CIA WHO HE LEFT THERE.
HE TRIED TO GET HIM OUT TWO
TIMES, SPENT $25 MILLION, HAD A
JET WAITING ON THE TARMAC,
PULLED BACK BY THE
STATE DEPARTMENT FOR SOME WEIRD
REASON.
HILLARY CLINTON INVOLVED.
BARACK OBAMA INVOLVED, PERHAPS
EVEN THE PREVIOUS ADMINISTRATION
INVOLVED.
THEY GO TO HIM AND THEY SAY WE
HAVE A COLLUSION IDEA.
HE SAYS THAT'S RIDICULOUS AND
THEY THEN SAY KEEP AN OPEN MIND
I UNDERSTAND.
>> THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT THEY SAY.
KEEP AN OPEN MIND, LET'S STAY IN
TOUCH.
>> Laura: OH, MY GOD, .
>> YET.
IT'S BEEN WHEN YOU HAVE SOURCES,
STRONG SOURCES FOR THIS.
>> I DO.
HE'S ON THE RECORD HIMSELF AND
HIS LAWYER AS WELL AS SEVERAL
FBI AGENTS IN THE STORY.
>> Laura: I ALSO UNDERSTAND
THAT HE OFFERED TO TESTIFY ON
CAPITOL HILL.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> Laura: TWO SOURCES ON THIS.
OFFER TO TESTIFY, DID NOT ASK
FOR IMMUNITY.
IT WAS REPORTED BY
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" FALSELY
THAT HE ASKED FOR IMMUNITY TO
TESTIFY AND I THINK SOMEONE IN
CONGRESS ALSO REPEATED THAT.
CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG.
HE DID NOT ASK FOR IMMUNITY.
WHY ARE THEY SMEARING THIS
PARTICULAR PERSON.
SPENT $25 MILLION TO TRY AND GET
HIM OUT OF IRAN.
>> A GREAT GUY, LET HIM IN THE
COUNTRY NO PROBLEM AND THEN WITH
THE SAME EVIDENCE, NOW ALL OF A
SUDDEN HE'S THE BAD GUY AGAIN.
>> Laura: THE GUY THEY WANT TO
USE TO PUSH THIS COLLUSION
THEORY.
IF YOU WANTED TO TRY TO GET OFF
COULD HAVE SAID I'M SURE PAUL
MANAFORT IS COLLUDING WITH SOME
PEOPLE, AGENTS, ROGUE HATREDS
AND RUSSIA.
WHAT CAN YOU GIVE ME?
HE DIDN'T DO THAT, CORRECT?
>> HE WAVED THEM OFF.
>> Laura: THIS IS UNBELIEVABLE
UNBELIEVABLE.
IT'S LIKE A NOVEL.
IT RETIRED FBI SPECIAL AGENT TOM
BAKER IS HERE IN WASHINGTON AND
ATTORNEY DILLON IN
SAN FRANCISCO.
THESE DETAILS ARE MOVING FAST
AND FURIOUS.
JOHN SOLOMON HAS DONE SOME OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT REPORTING ON
THIS CASE ON MUELLER, ON THE FBI
FOR MONTHS NOW AND NOW THIS.
TOM, I WANT TO START WITH YOU.
YOU KNEW BOB LEVINSON GOING BACK
TO THE FIRST PART OF THIS
NARRATIVE.
IF YOU KNEW HIM.
HE WORKED WITH HIM WHEN HE I
THINK WAS THAT COUNTERTERROR AND
YOU WERE AT THE FBI.
NOW WE HEAR MORE DETAILS ON THIS
RUSSIAN BILLIONAIRE SPENDING
$25,000,000,000.02 TIMES HE HAD
A GOOD HANDLE ON GETTING HIM OUT
OF THE COUNTRY.
TWICE AND HE WAS WAVED OFF
TWICE.
NOW THEY TRY TO USE THEM FOR THE
COLLUSION NONSENSE.
THIS IS AN OUTRAGE.
>> YES, IT IS.
IT IS, AND WHAT WAS IN OUTRAGE
WAS THE WAY THE WHOLE THING WAS
WAVED OFF.
BOB LEVINSON, ACROSS TRAILS WITH
HIM A COUPLE OF TIMES WHEN WE
WERE BOTH INVOLVED IN RUSSIAN
ORGANIZED CRIME.
I HAPPEN TO BE AT THAT TIME THE
LEGAL ATTACHE
LEGAL ATTACHÉ IN PARIS WHERE
DERIPASKA WOULD OFTEN STOP BY
HIMSELF.
HE SPENT A LOT OF TIME IN PARIS.
BUT LEVINSON, WE WOULD TRY TO DO
EVERYTHING WE COULD TO TRY TO
GET EVERY PART OF THE GOVERNMENT
MOVING ON HIM.
I WAS RETIRED WHEN HE WENT
MISSING.
WE GOT VERY LITTLE COOPERATION
FROM THE CIA AND VERY LITTLE
COOPERATION FROM THE
STATE DEPARTMENT AND THE FBI HAD
TO REACH OUT AND DO WHATEVER
THEY COULD THEMSELVES.
>> Laura: WHY -- THE FBI IS
ACTUALLY DOING THE WORK TO TRY
AND GET THE CIA GUY OUT,
REACHING OUT AND, AGAIN, I DON'T
KNOW IF IT'S ILLEGAL OR NOT.
WORKING WITH THIS GUY WHO HAD
BUSINESS INTERESTS IN IRAN,
REALLY RICH, REALLY CONNECTED
AND I BET DERIPASKA IT WANTED TO
KNOW WHY THE HECK AM I BEING
BANNED FROM COMING INTO THE
UNITED STATES, SHOW ME THE FILE
I'M SUCH A BAD GUY.
SHOW IT TO ME AND HE STARTS
WORKING WITH THEM.
MOTIVATIONS ASIDE, THAT WOULD
HAVE BEEN A GREAT THING TO GET
HIM OUT OF THE COUNTRY.
STATE DEPARTMENT TAKES BACK THE
DEAL AT THE LAST MOMENT ON SOME
SEEMINGLY SERIOUS GROUNDS.
GO AHEAD.
>> WHAT WE LEARN FROM SOLOMON'S
REPORTING IS THAT THIS WAS
PULLED OFF THE TABLE AT THE LAST
MINUTE BECAUSE HILLARY CLINTON
REFUSED TO SAY CERTAIN THINGS
THAT THE IRANIAN GOVERNMENT
WANTED SAID IN ORDER TO POINT A
FINGER AWAY FROM THEM.
SO THAT SAID, THIS GENTLEMAN AND
MOST WEALTHY PEOPLE IN HIS
POSITION DON'T DO THINGS OUT OF
NECESSARILY THE GOODNESS OF
THEIR HEART.
AND THERE WOULD HAVE BEEN AN
INTEREST IN IT FOR HIM AND
HAVING GOOD RELATIONS AND AN
ABILITY TO COME AND GO FROM THE
UNITED STATES IS LITERALLY WORTH
OVER $10 BILLION TO HIS
BUSINESSES SO NATURALLY HE
WANTED TO HELP AND DO A GOOD
THING AS LONG AS IT DIDN'T BLOW
BACK ON THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT.
HE WAS OUR SHORT OF THAT.
HE DID WHAT HE WAS ASKED.
McCABE WAS ONE OF THE PEOPLE
WHO RECRUITED HIM.
THIS IS HOW HE'S THANKS.
HE'S NOW ON A SANCTIONS LIST
AFTER, BY THE WAY, REFUSING TO
"KEEP AN OPEN MIND" WHEN FBI
AGENTS VISIT HIM.
HOW DO YOU KEEP AN OPEN MIND IF
YOU ARE ASKED DID A CRIME OCCUR?
KEEP AN OPEN MIND ABOUT IT.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
THAT'S INCREDIBLY SHADY AND
SUSPECT.
NOW WE HAVE A SECOND INSTANCE
HERE OF CLEARLY THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE AND FBI NOT GIVING
ALL THE INFORMATION TO THE FISA
COURT BECAUSE THIS IS WHAT WE
WOULD CALL EXCULPATORY EVIDENCE
IN A CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION
WHERE YOU ASK SOMEBODY DID
MANAFORT COLLUDE WITH THE
RUSSIANS ON BEHALF OF THE TRUMP
INVESTIGATION?
DERIPASKA WHO WOULD KNOW SAID
NO.
I HATE HIS GUTS, BUT HE DIDN'T
DO THAT.
I'M QUITE CERTAIN AS SOLOMON
JUST SAID THAT THAT WAS NOT
REVEALED TO THE FISA COURT
BECAUSE IF IT WERE, A JUDGE
WOULD TAKE A SECOND LOOK AT THAT
AND NOW MANAFORT IS FIGHTING IN
COURT FOR EVIDENCE OF WHETHER
THIS IS COVERED BY THE
ROSENSTEIN AUTHORIZATION AND
MUELLER HAS FILED THAT
INFORMATION UNDER SEALED.
THE FACT THAT THIS WHOLE
25 MILLION -- YOU HAVEN'T EVEN
TALKED ABOUT THE FACT THAT THE
$25 MILLION VIOLATES THE
ANTIDEFICIENCY ACT OF OUR
GOVERNMENT WHERE THE GOVERNMENT
IS NOT ALLOWED TO TAKE VOLUNTEER
SUPPORT FROM CITIZENS IF IT'S
NOT AUTHORIZED BY CONGRESS.
SO MUELLER MAY BE TRYING TO
COVER THAT UP BECAUSE IT'S
>> Laura: WELCOME BACK.
WE ARE CONTINUING OUR DISCUSSION
WITH JOHN SOLOMON ON THE BIG
STORY HE JUST BROKE.
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR BOB MUELLER
MAY BE TAINTED BY A CONFLICT OF
INTEREST IN THE RUSSIA PRO.
LET'S ALSO BRING IN FORMER FBI
AGENT ROBIN GRANT IN CHICAGO.
ROBIN SUPERVISED THE LEVINSON
CASE BACK IN 2009.
IF YOU JUST TUNED IN, BOB
LEVINSON, 30-YEAR VETERAN OF THE
CIA HELD NOW FOR 11 YEARS IN
IRAN.
WE LEARNED MORE DETAILS TONIGHT
ABOUT THE EFFORTS OF A RUSSIAN
BILLIONAIRE, DERIPASKA, NOW ON
THE U.S. SANCTIONS LIST TO
SECURE HIS RELEASE.
ON TWO DIFFERENT OCCASIONS
SPENDING $25 MILLION AND NOW WE
LEARN THAT DERIPASKA WAS
APPROACHED BY THE FBI IN
SEPTEMBER OF THE ELECTION YEAR.
IN SEPTEMBER 2016 WHERE THEY
FLOATED AN IDEA OF MANAFORT
MIGHT BE COLLUDING WITH TRUMP
AND WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT THAT
AND HE'S LIKE, I DON'T EVEN LIKE
MANAFORT.
THE FACTS ARE RIDICULOUS.
THE INTENT IS RIDICULOUS.
THAT'S ABSURD AND THE FBI
BASICALLY SAID KEEP AN OPEN
MIND.
THAT'S WILD.
ROBIN, I WANT TO GO TO YOU.
OF COURSE YOU WERE ON THIS CASE
FROM THE BEGINNING.
NOW WE ARE LEARNING MORE ABOUT
HOW THIS EFFORT WAS STRUNG
ALONG, SHUT DOWN, AT LEAST ON
ONE OCCASION OUT BY
HILLARY CLINTON.
YOUR THOUGHTS TONIGHT AS THESE
NEW DEVELOPMENTS ARE COMING OUT?
>> WHEN JOHN GAVE ME A CALL
ABOUT WHAT HE WAS FINDING OUT, I
WAS SHOCKED.
I HAD TAKEN OVER THE CASE ABOUT
SEVEN MONTHS AFTER BOB WAS
ARRESTED BY THE IRANIAN
AUTHORITIES.
AND WE WERE TURNING OVER EVERY
STONE TO BRING HIM BACK.
IN WORKING WITH A WHOLE
GOVERNMENT APPROACH TO BRING HIM
BACK.
AND NOW I HEAR AFTER I LEFT THE
CASE THAT THERE WAS ACTUALLY A
PLANE ON THE TARMAC AND BECAUSE
OF SOME CHANGES IN HIS
STATEMENT, THE AGREEMENT WENT
DOWNHILL AND BOB REMAINED IN
IRAN AND I THINK IS STILL THERE
TODAY.
>> Laura: WE HOPE HE STILL
ALIVE.
HE WOULD BE 80 YEARS OLD TODAY.
WE THINK JOHN SOLOMON, WE DON'T
LEAVE A MAN BEHIND IF AT ALL
POSSIBLE.
WE DON'T LEAVE A MAN BEHIND AND
IN THIS CASE HE WAS LEFT BEHIND
AND WE HAVE THE FBI AND McCABE
I GUESS TRYING TO BE CREATED
ABOUT DERIPASKA.
DERIPASKA BY THE WAY HAD HAD
CONVERSATIONS WITH
JOHN McCAIN.
DO WE KNOW WITH THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WERE ABOUT YEARS
AGO?
>> IT'S A STORY I BROKE IN
"THE WASHINGTON POST" TEN YEARS
AGO.
>> Laura: HEAVEN FORBID WE
ACTUALLY FIND OUT WHAT THE
CURRENT U.S. GOVERNMENT IS ALL
ABOUT.
GETTING BACK TO THE CONFLICT OF
INTEREST.
ALAN DERSHOWITZ AND JONATHAN
TURLEY HAD INTERESTING COMMENTS.
LET'S FIRST LOOK AT WHAT
JONATHAN TURLEY SAID ABOUT ALL
THIS.
HE'S CONCERNED ABOUT A POTENTIAL
CONFLICT.
HE SAID IF THE OPERATION WITH
DERIPASKA CONTRAVENED FEDERAL
LAW, THIS FIGURE COULD BE VIEWED
AS A POTENTIAL EMBARRASSMENT FOR
MUELLER.
THE QUESTION IS WHETHER HE COULD
IMPLICATE -- IT COULD IMPLICATE
MUELLER IN IMPROPRIETY.
AND THEN ALAN DERSHOWITZ SAYING
THIS.
HE ALSO HAD SIMILAR CONCERNS
ABOUT A POTENTIAL CONFLICT.
I THINK WE HAVE THE FULL SCREEN.
HE SAID THE REAL QUESTION
BECOMES WHETHER IT WAS PROPER TO
LEAVE HIM.
, DERIPASKA, OUT OF THE
V9 INDICTMENT.
AND WHETHER THAT OMISSION WAS TO
AVOID A KIND OF TRANSPARENCY
THAT IS REALLY REQUIRED BY THE
LAW.
>> I TALKED TO FOUR OR FIVE
LEGAL EXPERTS.
THEY ALL HAVE THE SAME
ASSESSMENT.
THEY ALL DIFFERENT VIEWPOINTS.
YOU SAID WE DON'T LEAVE ANY MEN
BEHIND HER THINK ABOUT HOW
DESPERATE THE FBI HAD TO BE TO
GO TO A RUSSIAN OLIGARCH AND SAY
COULD YOU FROM THIS BECAUSE THE
UNITED STATES WOULDN'T FUND IT.
THE CIA WOULD NOT GO BACK AND
GET THEIR OWN MEN TO THE LEVEL
THAT THE FBI THOUGHT IT DESERVED
SO THEY GO AND REACH OUT TO THE
SKY AND     AND A HALF TO FUND N
EXTRACURRICULAR ACTIVITY TO
RESCUE ONE OF OUR OWN MEN.
I THINK THAT'S ONE OF THE
SADDEST PARTS OF THE TALE THAT
GETS OVERLOOKED.
>> Laura: TOLD ME ABOUT
HILLARY CLINTON'S POTENTIAL
INVOLVEMENT?
>> WHAT WE KNOW IS FROM THE
FAMILY, DAVE McKAY, THE LAWYER
SAID THEY HAD A DEAL, DERIPASKA
CAME BACK, THEY WERE SENDING THE
PLANE TO THE TARMAC, WE ARE
GOING TO RESCUE HIM.
THERE WAS A STATEMENT THAT THE
IRANIAN GOVERNMENT WANTED IT
SAYING WE WERE INVOLVED IN
HILLARY CLINTON WAS UNABLE TO
GIVE THEM THAT ABSOLUTION.
THE PLANE LEFT AND HE WAS NEVER
RESCUED.
>> Laura: YOU KIND OF HAVE TO
SAY WHAT YOU'VE GOT TO SAY AT
THAT POINT.
SOME STUPID STATEMENT.
WHO CARES.
TO ME, THAT'S JUST A NOTHING.
YOU WONDER IF THERE WAS ANY
FUTURE CONCERN ABOUT ANY IRAN
DEAL DOWN THE ROAD.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT WAS GOING INTO
PLAY, BUT THEN YOU FAST-FORWARD,
ROBIN, TO THE FALL OF 2016.
SOME OF THESE AGENTS WHO
APPROACHED DERIPASKA AND HIS
APARTMENT IN NEW YORK, REMEMBER
HE'S ONLY ALLOWED TO COME INTO
THE UNITED STATES ON A FEW
OCCASIONS, ONE BY ONE VISA.
THEY APPROACH HIM AND THEY SAY,
FLOAT THIS COLLUSION IDEA.
AND HE'S LIKE WHAT?
COLLUSION?
WITH MANAFORT?
IS KIND OF LAUGHING AT THEM.
AND THEY ARE LIKE, KEEP AN OPEN
MIND.
THEY WERE ACTUALLY TRYING TO
COLLUDE WITH A RUSSIAN
BILLIONAIRE TO PUSH THE RUSSIAN
COLLUSION THEORY.
>> IT'S OUTRAGEOUS THAT ALL THIS
IS GOING ON.
IT'S STUFF THAT YOU SEE IN THE
MOVIES.
AND TO SEE THAT PEOPLE THAT WERE
WORKING FOR THE RELEASE OF
ROBERT LEVINSON HAVE NOW
SWITCHED AND ARE ACTUALLY
PUSHING A POLITICAL AGENDA AND
YOU SAID SOMETHING REALLY
INTERESTING ABOUT
HILLARY CLINTON AND THEN THE
IRAN DEAL.
AND I ACTUALLY WAS GONE FROM THE
FBI WHEN THE IRAN DEAL WAS
SIGNED AND I WAS WAITING FOR
BOB'S NAME TO BE READ.
I WAS WAITING FOR HIM TO COME
HOME AND WHEN HIS NAME WASN'T
READ, HEARTBREAKING, BECAUSE I
WANT TO CLARIFY THAT BOB WAS
ACTUALLY AN FBI AGENT FOR THAT
AMOUNT OF TIME.
IT WAS ALSO A DEA AGENT.
HE WAS JUST LIKE ANY OF US, WHEN
WE LEAVE GOVERNMENT SERVICE, WE
CONTRACT WITH PEOPLE.
AND YES HE WAS CONTRACTING WITH
ONE AGENCY BUT HE WAS TALKING TO
A LOT OF PEOPLE, ALL THE KIDS
AND EVERYTHING.
IT'S JUST THE FAMILY.
>> Laura: THE FAMILY HAS BEEN
THROUGH HELL, AND NOW THEY ARE
SUING IRAN.
I THINK REPUBLICANS ON THE HILL,
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE DEMOCRATS.
REPUBLICANS COULD       SHOULD C
REPUBLICANS COULD       SHOULD L
DERIPASKA TO WASHINGTON.
DON'T LIE AND SAY HE ASKED FOR
IMMUNITY, BECAUSE HE DIDN'T.
BRING HIM UP TO THE HILL, HEAR
WHAT HE HAS TO SAY.
SHARPLY QUESTIONING.
YOU DON'T THE TRUST WHAT HE
SAID.
QUESTION HIM.
I THINK THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
WOULD LIKE TO KNOW A LITTLE BIT
MORE ABOUT KEEPING THE BOGEYMAN
OF THE RUSSIAN BILLIONAIRES
ALIVE AND KEEP THE BIG FANTASY
ALIVE.
FANTASTIC REPORTING.
IT ROBIN, THANK YOU FOR WHAT
YOU'VE DONE FOR YOUR SERVICE TO
THIS COUNTRY.
ALL THOSE YEARS.
JOHN SOLOMON, PLEASE KEEP US
UP-TO-DATE ON YOUR REPORTING.
FANTASTIC REPORTING.